all right so I have gotten a lot of
requests to review this show and I
understand why because it's awesome
Dexter funny whenever I talk about the
show and I say Dexter people always like
oh yeah I know him in his laboratory
no not cartoon Dexter I mean serial
killer Dexter so Dexter is a show on
Showtime that's about pretty much it
serial killer right so story goes about
37 years ago officer Harry Morgan
arrived on a crime scene you found a
two-year-old kid and the kid had seen
some pretty messed up [ __ ] but the
officer adopts the kid anyway and then
the kid starts being about you know 6 8
10 12 and officer Harry Morgan notices
that his adopted kid does weird things
like you know kill the neighbor's dog
and kill rodents and then he recognizes
the kid's gonna be a serial killer
there's no way around it and so he
teaches him he's like alright I will
teach you how to kill people and get
away with it to keep you out of the
electric chair and they'll teach you a
code to live by aka you only kill serial
killers
so now Dexter's 37 years old he's all
grown up and he's learned to blend in
with society and he kills killers in a
weird ritualistic freaky serial killer
kind of way which is why he kills people
because he needs to kill people he wants
to kill people he's a serial killer he
doesn't kill people to be the dark
defender or anything like that and so
now you have an interesting premise for
a show and I've had some friends were
like freshmen in college we were taking
psych 101 the like surreal killers don't
work like that it wouldn't be how it
works they'll be a buzzkill enjoy the
show Dexter just finished its fifth
season so there's a lot to talk about I
could really review every season for the
sake of time I'll give you a general
overview of the show and what you can
expect when you watch it cuz you should
what I like about Dexter is Dexter is a
free individual we all have emotions and
things happen we have an emotional
response to things so everything to
yourself like that would be so awesome
if I didn't have an emotional response
to things like I only thought with my
brain that's Dexter Morgan like he was
at a restaurant with his girlfriend he
has his girlfriend who's pretty much
like camouflage to him she starts
growing on him after time and you know
he sees her as more than just camouflage
but in season one she is camouflage he
has to date this chick to blend in
because he knows that cops look for
singles thirty year old guys who live on
their own I was looking around this
restaurant he's just like I just don't
get these little mating rituals that
people have and the show is actually
really funny too in a really dark kind
of way it's not a comedy whenever I
explain the show to people who like is
it a comedy or a drama it is a drama
that has comedic moments in it which I
think dramas have a leg up on comedy
because comedies people expect them to
be funny because they're comedies if you
have a drama that has really dark funny
moments people
expect that [ __ ] and it turns out to be
a little funnier one of the funny
aspects of the show is that you can hear
Dexter Morgan's inner monologue you can
hear what he's thinking and then he says
the exact opposite of what he's thinking
you know because he has to say what
normal people would say he can't say
what he thinks otherwise people wouldn't
know he's a serial killer like there's
this one scene there at a crime scene
it's like a Friday night his friend
angel he's a cop on there is one of the
supporting characters he's like you know
what [ __ ] kill someone it makes us
work on a Friday night
Dexter nonchalantly just goes on then
Monday through Thursdays that's what I
always say the guys no idea that
Dexter's being completely serious about
that he only kills people on Monday
through Thursdays I guess I forgot to
mention that Dexter's job that's
important Dexter Morgan works as a blood
spatter expert for the Miami Metro PD
he's his lab geek no one suspects him of
being a serial killer except for a
couple people there have been a couple
people who are like they're just
something not right about that guy and
also what I like is that the seasons are
really different season four my favorite
John Lithgow plays a killer in season
four holy [ __ ] there are about three
people I can say that I've seen in
entertainment I'm like I actually
believe that guy is crazy the lotion
from the basket guy in Silence of the
Lambs is one Heath Ledger's Joker in the
Dark Knight that's two and John Lithgow
in season four of Dexter the three
craziest human beings I've seen in a
movie or a show and the supporting
characters in Dexter they're great too
my favorite side character has got to be
Vince Masuka for some odd reason he says
the funniest things in the show he's
just a really sick little bastard and I
like him and his sister Debra his sister
Debra's like the deepest of the
characters you see her grow over time
and season one she's a little more
insecure a little more not sure of
herself but in all the seasons she's
just really foul-mouthed cross-checked I
like her so I like the show Dexter and I
like the main character Dexter Michael C
Hall won a Golden Globe for his
portrayal of Dexter Morgan and he
absolutely deserved it was like three
years coming by the time he got it so
can you relate to and like a show about
a serial killer yeah probably
because it's awesome and it has my stamp
of approval it is one of my talk like
two favorite shows on TV but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more